ارتال عسكريه تابعه للقوات الدعم السريع
في شوارع الخرطوم واخرى في مدينه مروي
بالولايه الشماليه اعاده انتشار قابلها
الجيش بتحركات مماثله فنشرت قوتي في مناطق
عده بالعاصمه الخرطوم وارسل تعزيزات الى
محيط مطار مدينه مرو وقال انه يجهل خلفيات
هذا الانتشار الذي جرى دون التنسيق معه
وجب علينا ان ندق ناقوس الخطر
بان بلادنا تمر بمنعطف تاريخي وخطير
وتزداد مخاطره بقيام قياده قوات الدعم
السريع بتحشيد القوات والانفتاح داخل
العاصمه وبعض المدن
قوات الدعم السريع قالت من جانبها ان
تحركاتها جاءت وفقا للقانون وحذرت من
مواصفات بشائعات التي تزرع الفتنه وتقوض
استقرار الوطن وامنه الازمه بين الجيش
وقوات الدعم السريع دفعت القوى السياسيه
الى عقد اجتماع طارئ لبحث الازمه واجر
الاتفاق على ارسال وفد الى كلا الطرفين
لوقف التصعيد الاعلامي والعسكري وتوصلوا
الى
رؤيه مشتركه
بان الامر
يتطلب
جمع الصف الوطني
مدنيين وعسكريين
وينظر الى هديه التوترات على انها امتداد
للخلافات بين الجيش وقوات الدعم السريع
بشان كيفيه الادماج والتباعد مواقفهما من
الاتفاق الايطالي الذي اجل تنفيذه اكثر من
مره نتيجه هذه الخلافات وهذا الاعتقان
المستمر والطويل بلغت هذه الازمه اشدها
ربما هذا التصعيد يكون لقسم مواقف تفاعليه
الان ولكن يمكن ان ينفلت لانه من الصعوبه
من مكان ان تحقق مواقف او كسوف تفاوضيه عن
طريق المناورات العسكريه
خلافات سياسيه اذا بين قوات الجيش
السوداني والدعم السريع تحولت الى خلافات
عسكريه وترجمت بالنشر القوات للدعم السريع
في مروي قبل ان تشاهد اليات تابعه لتلك
القوات في العاصمه الخرطوم في وقت تسعى
فيه القوى السياسيه للتهدئه وتجنب حدوث
تصعيد لن تحمد عقبه الطاهره المرضي
الجزيره الخرطوم